100 euro sind 104 schweizer franken 2400
bis 12.000 yen oder 1,6 millionen
indonesischen warte mal genau das hatten
wir doch vor einigen wochen schon mal
als 400 euro in new york aufgegeben
haben ja aber mit diesem betrag waren
uns an manchen stellen wirklich die
hände gebunden bei new york ist einfach
ging teuer wie sehr unterscheidet sich
also ein tag an dem man quasi
unbegrenzte möglichkeiten hat und sich
quasi alles kaufen kann was man möchte
und vor allem lohnt es sich viel spaß
mit dem video 1000 euro in new york city
als allererstes müssen wir aber was
speisen geben denn wir brauchen genug
stärkung um heute die ganzen
attraktionen über den tag wegstecken zu
können ich hätte die möglichkeit gehabt
hier von den zuschauern george essen zu
gehen ist ein super bekannter new yorker
koch bei dem trump und alle helfer
hessen gehen weil er so ein ganz
spezielles helmut hat das christoph
letzte woche auf seinem youtube kanal
gezeigt hat aber ich glaube das wäre
dann doch ein bisschen zu teuer geworden
deswegen habe ich mich dafür entschieden
im höchsten restaurant oder sich finden
konnte essen zu gehen und das befindet
sich hinter mir eigentlich sollte das
1000 euro projekt erst dann kommen wenn
alle 100 euro videos aus den
verschiedensten ländern gekommen sind
aber cupid macht mir wie so häufig einen
strich durch die rechnung und es gibt
quasi keine möglichkeit für mich nach
japan indonesien oder andere
interessante länder zu reisen um dort
100 euro auszugeben deswegen kommt
dieses video jetzt
[Musik]
35 stock und ich weiß nicht ob es schon
erkennen konnte wir sind direkt am
central park also wenn das alles so ist
mir vorstelle dann werden wir gleich
perfekten blick auf den central park
ich sitze jetzt der ausblick ist
wirklich phänomenal aber ich glaube die
preise auch wenn die preise stehen nicht
auf dem i ich habe einen burger
orangensaft kaffee und wasser bestellt
das würde schätzen ist wahrscheinlich so
das günstigste was man hier bekommen
kann der bürger jetzt bin ich richtig
gespannt bis der bürger kommt wenig sich
aber noch weiter die aussicht
und natürlich ist es wie immer super und
wir nehmen damit er kann man also einen
guten restaurant oder einen anderen
platz zu sitzen wo es eine menge leute
gibt die keinen bock haben das ebenso
gefällt mir aber was sollte ich scheiße
drauf ja das sieht alles super aus wir
haben die krasse aussicht und sitzen in
einem absoluten luxus restaurant aber
mir ist direkt aufgefallen das ist alles
nur halb so viel spaß macht wenn man
alleine da ist also egal wie viel luxus
werden dem tag erleben werden und was
ich mir alles kaufen kann alleine macht
es nur halb so viel spaß ist
okay das war wirklich ein erlebnis der
ausblick war einmalig aber wir haben
knapp 100
also völlig wird 100 dollar für einen
burger pommes und orangensaft
ausgeliehen das macht ihnen keiner welt
sind aber es gibt natürlich auch sachen
und erlebnisse bei denen es sinn macht
ein bisschen mehr geld in die hand
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch dass
wir im 100 euro projekt den ganzen tag
hier in fahrer darum gefahren sind mit
sowas geben uns heute natürlich nicht ab
deswegen bestelle ich jetzt zur nächsten
attraktion und jetzt jetzt komplett
krank noch bevor ich beim helipad
angekommen bin habe ich schon die
nächste attraktion um eine ganz
bestimmte personen action sehen zu
können dazu aber später mehr oh mein
gott es geht los er ist es völlig krank
ich werde gleich in einem helikopter der
baugleich ist zudem der hinter mir steht
über new york fliegen und das genauso
wie er hier steht also tatsächlich ohne
türen ich werde dort sitzen und meine
füße rausstrecken können ich habe das
schon sehr oft vorhergesehen und die
ganze zeit schon gedacht wenn ich mal
irgendwann nach new york schaffen sollte
und das geld dazu habe dann will ich das
unbedingt machen vor drei tagen bin ich
das erste mal helikopter geflogen das
hat mir so laune gemacht das geht als ok
ich muss das so schnell wie es geht
wieder machen und jetzt bin ich bei
fleisch eiern und werde gleich 20
minuten über die new yorker skyline mit
offenen türen fliegen ok es muss so
ungefähr alles hier in diesen locker
bleiben ich darf nichts mit nehme ich
darf quasi mein handy und meine kamera
mitnehmen ansonsten muss alles hier
bleiben die taschen müssen komplett leer
sein und ich habe nochmal externen auf
30 minuten + ich glaube ich bin komplett
alleine in den helikopter also wirklich
völlig alleine das wäre ein traum jetzt
geht's los
okay es geht scheinbar losgelaufen neben
den anderen staaten helikoptern her und
mit komplett amt der pilot und ganz da
vorne sich um unternehmen kommt da jetzt
30 minuten backen
o
der sieht so krass aus
[Musik]
ich sehe vielleicht etwas komisch aus
mit den kopfhörern jetzt und ohne kappe
aber ich habe den platz neben dem
kinopublikum absoluter traum und jetzt
geht's los
[Musik]
das war es der halbe stunde ist rum der
flug war unglaublich hinter mir geht die
sonne gehabt darunter der himmel ist
unglaublich schön wir haben
sonnenuntergang über new york erlebt
wären wir in dem helikopter waren das
geld hat sich allemal gelohnt also wenn
ihr mal in new york seit das lohnt sich
wirklich das war unglaublich ist eine
menge spaß gemacht zu der firma gehören
irgendwie sechs helikopter oder sohn die
fliegen die ganze zeit die ganze zeit
also es ist wirklich richtig richtig
geil und bevor wir jetzt zum absoluten
highlight kommen worauf ich mich schon
freuen bevor ich nach new york gekommen
bin gehen wir als allererstes in diesem
laden essen ich bin gespannt wie viel es
kostet ich weiß nichts außer dass ein
sehr gutes restaurant sein soll und ich
freue mich vielleicht auch mal wieder
ein bisschen gemüse oder so zu essen
weil das in den letzten tagen wirklich
zu kurz gekommen
[Musik]
auf den unteren etagen scheint es hier
so luxusmöbel raus zu sein team gespannt
was mich erwartet die sachen die hier
stehen sich auf jeden fall sehr gut und
sehr teuer auf
ich muss die kamera weg tun weil hier
spezielle gäste sind zur vorspeise gab
es gegrillte artischocken super super
lecker und gleichzeitig habe ich aber
trotzdem gemerkt dass obwohl ich in
einem super high class restaurant setze
mir die bedienung trotz alledem zum
hauptgang so ein typisch amerikanisches
sandwich empfohlen hat also selbst als
ich mal ein bisschen gesünder essen
wollte war die empfehlung eine absolut
fertige aber der laden an sich war auch
superschön die bedingungen waren super
aufmerksam und mega professionell das
hat sich auf jeden fall genug nach dem
essen ging es für mich direkt zur
absolut amerikanischen traum sportart
nein ich rede nicht von football sondern
von basketball mit einem absoluten
topspiel lakers gegen nix im madison
square garden von allem muss mich jetzt
aber ran halten das spiel gerade schon
mal angefangen hat
fucking madison square garden
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch noch wie ich gerade
eben gesagt habe dass ich eine ganz
bestimmte person in action sehen bilden
quasi eine legende ein absoluter
weltstar natürlich rede ich von lebron
james und zu meinem glück hat er in
diesem spiel die erste sperre seines
lebens gehabt weswegen ich ihn nicht
spielen sehen konnte naja was solls
trotzdem lakers gegen nix ein absolutes
traumspiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fazit ich habe tausend euro an einem tag
ausgegeben tatsächlich hat es sich quasi
gar nicht gelohnt der helikopter flug
war ein absoluter traum und abseits
davon waren die ausgaben absolut unnötig
gerade weil ich am tag davor erlebt habe
wie gut man mit 100 euro eigentlich in
new york schon zurecht kommt mein new
york als stadt einfach so viel zu bieten
hat klar für ein youtube video kann man
sich sowas mal gönnen und es ist cool zu
zeigen was möglich ist würde ich dass
irgend jemand von euch raten auf keinen
fall würde ich noch mal machen würde ich
privat machen auf keinen fall trotz
alledem hat es natürlich eine menge
laune gemacht dass lakers game war ein
absoluter traum das essen war gut und es
war ein wirkliches erlebnis vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren wenn ich
das video gefallen hat und wir sehen uns
am donnerstag wieder
[Musik]